want to know what taught in theaters  this weekend we're gonna kill every last  one of them Milla Jovovich returns to  battle the umbrella corporation in  resident evil the final chapter this was  me and then this was me  then I came back as this little guy in a  dog's purpose a reincarnated dog learns  the reason for his existence did you  find that it's amazing how little gold  does everything Matthew McConaughey  plays a down-and-out businessman who  goes to Indonesia to search for treasure  in gold we're talking over 30 billion  dollars and finally let's find out  what's hot in theaters this weekend with  this week's fantasy patient  so what's your weekend ticket going to  be let us know in the comments below  we'll see you next time on weekend  ticket  [Music]